SMUGNESS AND GROUP THINK.
BE SURE TO TUNE IN TOMORROW
NIGHT NEW HAMPSHIRE RESULTS AT
THAT HOUR.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THINK YOU ARE
WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
BROADCASTING LIVE IN BEAUTIFUL
BEDFORD, NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE WE
ARE TRACKING SEVERAL MAJOR
BREAKING STORIES TONIGHT AS WE
SPEAK.
ALL EYES ON THE GRANITE LIVE
FREE DIE STATE AND THAT IS THE
FIRST PRIMARY POLLS THAT WILL
OPEN IN A FEW HOURS.
MEANWHILE DOWN THE ROAD IN
MANCHESTER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WRAPPED UP ANOTHER MASSIVE
RALLY.
I WILL TAKE YOU THERE, OUR OWN
LAWRENCE JOAN HAS BEEN IN THE
CROWD ALL NIGHT.
EARLIER TODAY, YES, YOURS TRULY,
I MADE A SURPRISE VISIT TO WHAT
WAS A TINY, ITSY-BITSY, SPARSELY
ATTENDED BIDEN CAMPAIGN EVENTS.
A DIP PRESSING TO SITE TO BE
BLUNT AND MANY IN THE AUDIENCE
WILL BUS STAND AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THERE, WHEN I TALK TO
THEM, THEY WERE NOT SUPPORTING
QUID PRO QUO JOE BUT THEY ARE
FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT.
HERE IS A PREVIEW.
IT GETS INTERESTING WHAT WENT
DOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOE BIDEN IS ON TAPE SAYING
YOU ARE NOT GETTING $1 BILLION
IN LESS YOU FIRE A PROSECUTOR
WHO IS INVESTIGATING HIS SON,
HIS NO EXPERIENCE, OIL/GAS
ENERGY UKRAINE AND YET GETTING
PAID MILLIONS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
>> I HAVE NO COMMENT.
>> I THINK THAT IS A RED
HERRING.
>> RED HERRING?
>> TO TAKE THE CLIENT -- --
>> TRUMP WAS ACQUITTED FOR LIFE.
>> BY US AND THAT THAT WAS --
>> Sean: YOU’RE NOT ANSWERING
MY QUESTION.
>> I’M SURE ALL OF YOUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS WILL GET MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO GET PAID FOR
DOING A KNOWING NOTHING WITH
NO EXPERIENCE.
THAT HAPPENS TO ALL OF US,
RIGHT?
I GUESS IF WE HIT THE LOTTERY.
THE FULL TAPE COMING UP WHICH IS
VERY ENTERTAINING.
BUT FIRST, WE ARE ONLY 267 DAYS
UNTIL THE ELECTION.
YOU WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOCK
THE WORLD ONCE AGAIN, AND THIS
IS POLITICAL CRUNCH TIME.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WE CAN
REPORT TONIGHT IS AN UTTER STATE
OF COMPLETE SHAMBLES.
IT IS A MESS.
THE IOWA CAUCUS, A TOTAL
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
THE FIELD OF 2020 DEMOCRATS SO
WEAK, SO RADICAL, SO EXTREME
MANY PARTY INSIDERS ARE ACTUALLY
FREAKING OUT ON THE OUTSIDE.
77-YEAR-OLD QUID PRO QUO JOE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE FRESH NEW
FACE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LOOK AT THE THREE OLDER, LET’S
SEE, BLOOMBERG, BIDEN,
BERNIE SANDERS AND IT LOOKS LIKE
500 YEARS OLD COMBINED APPEARED
SUPPOSED TO BE THE FRONT RUNNER,
BUT AFTER A PATHETIC
FOURTH-PLACE FINISH IN IOWA, HIS
CAMPAIGN IS FLAILING AND THE
POLLS HERE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE NOT
LOOKING GOOD EITHER.
OVER THE WEEK END AGITATED AND
VERY FRANKLY AGAIN INCOHERENT
JOE SNAPPING AT A 21-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN ATTENDING ONE OF HIS
TOWN HALLS.
NOT THE FIRST TIME HE’S BEEN
SNAPPING AT PEOPLE THOUGH.
WHO HE’S ASKING TO VOTE FOR HIM.
SHE DARED TO ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT THE IOWA CAUCUS AND
ELECTABILITY.
HE SAID, YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS UP,
THAT THE YOUNG WOMAN HAD A DOG
FACE.
AND CALLED THE WOMAN,
21-YEAR-OLD WOMAN A LIAR.
GREAT JOB, JOE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THE
PERFORMANCE IN IOWA, AND WHY
SHOULD THE VOTERS BELIEVE THAT
YOU CAN WIN THE NATIONAL
ELECTION?
>> IT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
NUMBER ONE, I IOWA IS A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO A CAUCUS?
NO, YOU HAVEN’T.
YOU ARE A LYING DOG FACE PONY.
NOW I HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING IN
IOWA.
>> Sean: FIRST OF ALL HE SAID
I AM AN IOWA CAUCUS.
WHAT?
JOE 30330 AND THEN HE SAYS
221-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WHO ARE LYING
DOG FACE PONY SOLDIER SUPPOSED
TO BE THE DEMOCRATIC FRONT
RUNNER AND REALLY CONNECTING
WITH THE POST AND THE PEOPLE,
WE, THE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE THAT
HE WANTS TO VOTE FOR HIM.
THAT IS THEIR TOP CANDIDATE.
THIS IS NOW THE THIRD TIME QUID
PRO QUO JOE WAS CAUGHT ON CAMERA
BEING RUDE, NASTY TO VOTERS.
HE SAID THAT HE WAS ONLY JOKING.
DIDN’T LOOK LIKE A JOKE TO ME.
BUT THE 21-YEAR-OLD COLLEGE
STUDENT AT THE RECEIVING END OF
THIS RAGE, WELL, SHE’S NOT
LAUGHING TONIGHT.
IN FACT, SHE IS INSULTED THAT
THEY ARE PRETENDING THIS WAS
SOME BIG, FUNNY JOKE.
SHE SAID QUID PRO QUO JOE
HUMILIATED HER AND "HE HAS BEEN
PERFORMING EXTREMELY POORLY IN
THE RACE AND THE FACT HE
COULDN’T ANSWER A STRAIGHT
QUESTION WITHOUT BOWLING OR
INTIMIDATING JUST EXACERBATES
THE FACT."
SHE IS RIGHT AND TONIGHT JENKINS
WAS ABLE TO INTERVIEW THE
21-YEAR-OLD STUDENT.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> FRANKLY WHEN HE SPEAKS, A LOT
OF WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
TASTELESS AND VERY SAD.
AND WE HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
DEATH AND CANCER IN PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOB.
TO ME, HE DOESN’T VERY SAME
SOLUTION ORIENTED IN HOW TO FIX
THOSE PROBLEMS.
I DON’T THINK HE HAS THE
MOMENTUM TO CARRY THIS TO A
NATIONAL ELECTION.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, NOT
EXACTLY THE LOOK FOR SOMEONE WHO
AT THIS POINT PROBABLY NEEDS
EVERY VOTE HE CAN GET.
OF COURSE, THE CAMPAIGN HAS MORE
CAUSE FOR CONCERN THEN BIDEN’S
DERANGED RANTINGS THAT ARE
FRANKLY UNHINGED.
THERE ARE DOZENS OF LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER AND HIS SHADY BUSINESS
DEALINGS, NOT ONLY IN UKRAINE
BUT CHINA AND OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND THEN QUID PRO QUO JOE
UKRAINIAN SHAKEDOWN, REMEMBER
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
DOLLARS, $1 BILLION UNLESS YOU
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCED SON.
WOW, QUID PRO QUO JOE DOESN’T
HAVE ANY ANSWERS TO THAT
QUESTION.
EVERY TIME HE HAS ASKED, A A
WEEK AT HIS INDIGNANT RAGE AND
OF COURSE THE MEDIA MOB NEVER
PUSHES HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS BETTING
INFORMATION FROM RUDY GIULIANI
ABOUT YOUR SONS WORK IN UKRAINE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS MAY BE ON?
>> RUDY GIULIANI?
[LAUGHTER]
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION -- >> DO
YOU THINK YOUR SON IS FAIR GAME
HERE?
>> HIS SON OR MY SON?
>> YOUR SON HUNTER?
>> I DON’T THINK OUR SONS ARE
FAIR GAME AT ALL.
NO ONE SAID HE DID ANYTHING
WRONG EXCEPT THE THUG, RUDY
GIULIANI, COME ON!
RUDY GIULIANI?
CAN WE JUST --
>> Sean: IN THE SAME RUDY
GIULIANI WHO ALMOST DIED 9/11
AND WAS THERE TO REALLY LEAD A
COUNTRY, THAT GUY THAT WENT UP
AGAINST HIM UP AND BECAME ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST PROSECUTORS IN
HISTORY?
THE GUY THAT TURNED
NEW YORK CITY WHICH WAS A DUMP
FROM WHATCOM AT 3,000 MURDERS A
YEAR OR THEREABOUTS TO 300?
THAT SAME RUDY GIULIANI?
OKAY, HE’S CONTROVERSIAL BUT
THAT DOESN’T ANSWER THE
QUESTION, JOE.
WHAT DOES YOUR ZERO EXPENSE --
EXPERIENCE ON, GET MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
AND HOW IS IT THAT YOU USED
ROPE -- LEVERAGE SHAKING DOWN
THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE AND SAID
YOU’RE NOT GETTING $1 BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE HIM.
YOU HAVE SIX HOURS AND SON OF A
B, THEY FIRED HIM.
WOULD YOU LAUGH IF THAT WAS
DONALD TRUMP AND
DONALD TRUMP JR.?
ANYWAY JOE 3033 OH IS IN A
FREE FALL AND GETTING NASTY AND
NEGATIVE AND TURNING ON HIS
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS INCLUDING
THIS BRAND-NEW AD AGAINST
POOR MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG WHO
DIDN’T EXACTLY HAVE THE BEST
TRACK RECORD IN THE INDIANA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BOTH BIDEN AND BUTTIGIEG HAD
MADE OUR DECISIONS.
DESPITE PRESSURE FROM THE NRA,
JOE BIDEN PASSED A SALT WEAPONS
THROUGH CONGRESS.
AND THEN HE PASSED VIOLENCE AND
EVEN WHEN PUBLIC PRESSURE
MOUNTED AGAINST HIM, FORMER
MAYOR PETE FIRED THE FIRST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN POLICE CHIEF.
AND THEN HE FORCED THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FIRE CHIEF AULT
TOO.
WE ARE ELECTING A PRESIDENT.
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE MATTERS.
>> Sean: AFTER DAYS OF VOTE
COUNTING, MAYOR PETE APPARENTLY
WAS THE BIG WINNER OUT OF IOWA
IF ANYONE BELIEVES THOSE
NUMBERS.
AND AS THE BIDEN AD POINTS OUT
HE STRUGGLES WITH MINORITIES.
HE DIDN’T LOOK AT OVER THE
WEEKEND IN THAT DEBATE.
HE FIRED SOUTH BEND’S VERY FIRST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN POLICE CHIEF
AND FORCED HEALTHY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FIRE CHIEF AS
WELL.
AND DURING THE LAST PATHETICALLY
BORING, UNWATCHABLE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE, NOT ONLY WATCHED IT SO
YOU DIDN’T HAVE TO AND THIS
WONDERFUL AUDIENCE OF HOURS, HE
COULDN’T ANSWER A QUESTION ABOUT
WHY HE OVERSAW A MASSIVE SPIKE
AND MAJORITY DRUG ARRESTS DURING
HIS TIME AS MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND.
MAYOR PETE MIGHT BE SEEING A
SURGE IN THE POLLS BUT NOT
EXACTLY POPULAR WITH HIS OWN
CONSTITUENTS.
HE IS NOW BATTLING FOR FIRST
PLACE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE AND THE